foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
baby we are back it is Tuesday it is an
NBA Tuesday right here on the bleach
Report app and we're going to get right
to it actually before we get to it I got
to introduce This I Gotta introduce
everybody that you see here my name is
Greg Ivory next to me is the man I call
MB that stands for Michael Bolin and
next to him is the producer the producer
producer Ryan uh appreciate you guys for
being here appreciate you guys for
tapping in I know uh
you guys are looking forward to doing
this show we're looking forward to doing
this parlay we're looking forward to
catching last week though let's talk
about it guys last week
we hit four legs
but we did not complete the job today we
need to complete the job we need your
help we need you guys help at home in
order for us to complete the job we need
your help I'm gonna ask you guys to vote
give us thumbs up thumbs Downs on pick
you guys respond to us uh but man are
you Michael Bolin producer Ryan should
we just get right into it
I just want to make one quick comment
about clay selling that was the most
depressing watch and I don't want to
have bad vibes all night but no we have
to make sure that this first pick is
solid because clay was our first pick
last time
so make sure let's make sure we get a
good one that's true I also
go ahead go ahead Greg sorry no I was
just gonna I was just gonna
vouch and then the repeat after Michael
Bolin and tell the people though let's
please make sure let's make sure we're
locked and loaded from the first pick to
the last because we were locked and
loaded from pick two to five last week
we got to be locked and loaded from pick
one to five but Ryan what are the people
talking about in the chat
uh I'm already seeing Anthony Davis 10
plus rebounds from uh lay low 11.
um and and rad says I need Faith
restored uh you're not the only one
brother I need Faith restored as well
um so you said it Greg earlier you said
I'm all about accountability that we
didn't get the job done we got the job
done last week clay didn't get the job
done that's all right we we did
everything else we did everything else
we needed we needed him to score and he
didn't do that
I made all my shots I don't know that's
true
yes I didn't I didn't take any but I
didn't miss any
hey so guys let's let's just let's just
be clear so the audience are we sticking
to the TNT games are we making this are
we making this call right now guys
should we just stick to the TNT games
yeah yeah I have I have beef with what
we did last week because FanDuel runs a
promo that it's a there's a no sweat uh
like up to 25 if it's only the TNT games
and we added a non-tnt game uh last week
and when we lost I was like oh at least
I'll get a free 25 bet and and I didn't
get that so uh we're sticking to TNT
tonight that's on us that's on us
it's on all of us yeah like I said
accountability
let's pick the TNT guys let's stick to
TNT I see a lot of people is popping off
in the comments should we just get it
started we got to get it started with
the first one guys guys this isn't what
I'm what I'm locking in I'm just
bringing a suggestion here we got we got
uh my man semi bert23
it says Braun 10 assists
the producer the producer just whispered
in my ear and says Lakers Cavs Lakers
Cavs yeah
Lakers Cavs and he said Brawn 10 assists
where we don't have to lock it in we
just got to get a conversation starter
going
okay so all right
look
it's over under it's five and a half
that's so much
wait wait wait wait wait all right so I
get I partially get it because we now
have told the entire audience that you
can get a free BET back so it almost
feels like we're gonna have like the
craziest takes in here like we've had
what a six to one parlay I think last
week was pretty close seven to one
something like that I feel like people
want like a 12 to 1 parlay today and I'm
not gonna be the person to tell them
they can't have it so that's what I
think
and Greg you know I don't I don't ever
turn that opportunity down
I know I know y'all see my face like I
just went right away from winning and
now we're sitting here debate is not
going big on this bike I'm just trying
to win guys
Greg needs winners I appreciate that
that's it hey let's talk to the people
though let's talk to the people yeah
LeBron James over points it's free money
that's what Jake mcmengan 11 22 says his
game against his former teams his
overall points he says free money
against his older uh his I'm sorry his
games against his older teams our former
teams
26 and a half doesn't seem like too much
to me in this spot I think that he'll
probably get really close to that number
my caution is that since last week A.D
has been playing his ass off he had a 55
point game recently so you got to think
that this game may not be super high
scoring I think 26 and a half maybe too
many but we could get a little lower
than that potentially because I do love
the narrative he loves going home and
planting Cleveland so I do like the pick
so whoever dropped that I think that's
right on yeah we are also you mentioned
A.D uh the iron Evans dropped uh A.D
over 26 and a half points is what the
streets are saying
oh wow I like talking streets the
streets is also sitting Barlow worlds
Barlow world is saying James over 26 and
a half points also Dominic schultzman
LeBron James over 25 and a half no 26
and a half points uh so
I mean the people are talking
should we lock this in and just get a
vote so we could see like what we get a
temperature check
I like it I do like the ad pick I do
like I do like the 80 pick but the Ryan
you have to get the people to vouch we
need at least two to three people in the
comment vouching yeah
but let's start off with Brian
go ahead Ryan talk talk no no it's just
like do we need to start off with like a
straight over under or can we like tease
this down a little bit
let's do
let's tease it down brother you're the
producer man dude yeah
yeah oh my goodness
the people are telling us to start it up
we we have we can get something down all
right let's why don't oh my God that's
not enough all right 25 fine 25 25.
let me get this out of here
it looks guys
oh that's stupid no that's not bro
that's no we should not do that we
should not do that like that's a minus
look at look at the odds
minus 190. yeah what what's the problem
and
and over 26 and a half that's like one
and a half point was minus 115
yeah
I'm frustrated just put it we're saving
ourselves from a bad beat yeah if
there's a bat if Greg if there's a bad
beat and we didn't take this I I'm mind
blown I'm mind-blown that this is coming
from you out of all people out of Mister
go big or go home
Mr 21 to one parlays only and you're
sitting here telling me that you want to
take a minus 190 compared to a minus 115
over one and a half point this is my
favorite show in the world I will say
this if we take over 26 and a half and
he finishes at 25 or 26. I'm a person
you're gonna see me in your venmo
requests
real chat is saying nrad 257 saying
minus 199 25 nah I'm good somebody's
saying you might as well 26 and a half
give the people what they want exactly
what are we why are we even having this
conversation right I'm just mind blown
it's with you
Mr Gold bigger go home
okay
spicy sponge Ryan come on I'm with Greg
all right everyone's with you Greg
everyone's with you we'll move on we'll
move on people are saying they want
they want Anthony Davis though
Ian Evans jumped in before it said over
26 and a half but I don't I don't want
to do two Lakers over 26 and a half yeah
that's crazy
there's no way to do that because I feel
like that's just that's assuming that
this is going to be a really high
scoring and close game I think there's
an opportunity for the Cleveland
Cavaliers to maybe blow them out tonight
so I don't know I don't think that
betting both of them here is a smart
spot but we'll let the chat decide I
mean I think
you can make a case for both of them to
score that
all right let's I mean I love the ad
play but if Ryan doesn't want to do that
and The Vibes no are not good I do too I
honestly like the AG play better than
LeBron but this is a parlay of the
people so like I think we just have to
figure out a way to get in because like
Bagel unlocks our guy Logan Gellers in
here saying this is an Anthony Davis
Knight I agree with that we just got to
figure out I don't think it just has to
be points all right we can we can talk
about it at the end we can talk about it
at the end we could at the half the
people decide if we're going to go with
Broner A.D we know we're going to go to
with a point total we know we want to go
with a point guard we have to figure
that out but let's move on let's move on
I see other people in the comments uh I
see Lonnie Walker 15 plus I see Russ to
cover his assist total a lot I've seen
that a lot yeah throughout
the chat saying the same thing
should we just put it down and let the
people vote
yeah
over six and a half six and a half
I mean do you want to go look at some
alternates
um
I mean we can get smart about it yeah
we're playing ping pong what's smart and
silly over here and this is pretty good
yeah just throw the minus 1000 in there
it'll hit it'll hit
so so that's minus 185
but his line is six and a half
come on bro come on
why are we even having this discussion
like what this is twice in literally two
minutes oh my God I'm so there's no way
you're steering okay okay Ryan here's my
explanation
we know now and we've informed yeah why
are you buying half a point for like we
are gonna get the money back if it
doesn't hit anyway so why would we err
on the side of caution when it's a free
it's a free roll
now
look at this
it's begging us to take it yeah I don't
want to but we're telling you to take it
hey Ryan oh my God bro
you're funny hey Ryan you are hilarious
uh you you wanted to buy a point
go ahead bowling go ahead
I'm looking at the chat and everybody
agrees with us and they're not agreeing
with Ryan and I think it's effecting him
it's messing me up I'm usually a man of
the chat I look down and put my buddy in
the chat is agreeing
uh you do have some support Dominic
schultzman says safe call on this one
Russ six assists
yeah I also see flip dollar 23 saying
Anthony Davis over three assists but
let's not forget we do have another game
we need to cover here so that's true we
definitely did we definitely look
as well
all right yeah I've been seeing Luca I
saw a lot of people say Luca saw a lot
of people talk about Luca
um
we'll see we need you guys to fill these
comments up what do you guys like about
this Dallas Mavericks Denver Nuggets
game y'all let us know Lucas sitting at
32 and a half
that's a lot of points but he's been
covering that number a lot man it's
impressive to see what he's been doing I
mean 40 Point triple doubles he had four
I mean the night I think sometime last
we get 40 12 and 12 or something crazy
like that so I don't know hey Ryan the
people are so fun they're they're
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're they're they're feeling
they're feeling the compassion for you
they're saying he has been through some
bad beats so that's why he wants to buy
buy point this is down uh I've been
through war with these bets yeah man
they're fairly compassionate uh all
right here we go Luca 25 points I feel
like that's going to be a lot of juice
somebody said that uh
773-1985 says Luca 25 points uh AK-47 39
says Lucas two threes
oh yeah there you go caught my eye yep
and the line's two and a half and we're
gonna go straight to two
and there we go what do we think
I like it
legs in here so we definitely gotta have
some lucky legs
they're uh that that looks good to me uh
not seeing much about the job oh I guess
here here we go Ricky Maria saying Joker
triple double I don't know if we can add
that to this parlay but that does mean
he's gonna grab a bunch of boards so if
anyone has takes on the Joker I mean
this is a pretty awesome matchup for The
nightcap tonight on TNT
I actually like his assess most of the
time
foreign
yeah all right here we go
um
I see some people in the comments joke
it's 10 boards 10 boards
what's this
oh my God it said ten and a half we
already know how this is gonna go
no right no we'll let dragons
you know this man is gunshot now because
everything he does is just gonna get
fired up in the [ __ ]
I'm not gonna have to take you guys know
where I stand on this you guys go ahead
I'm gonna let you guys
all right so Ryan if we put nine
rebounds instead of ten would you feel
better about that
I don't know if we can do nine
two we could do we could do eight and
it wouldn't do anything no
so what do we have just I just want you
to get back to normal man I I really
feel like today has really met through a
wrench in your producer skills and
you're being gunshot I need you to come
with your like strong hearted takes just
like always because we will continue we
will move in Patty Drew says Ryan is
playing scared
hey so look it so look at uh I actually
got a scoop guys Jaden Joyner said he
has 16 boards against a map last game
he thinks he can get 10 tonight
I like it that's the scoop right there
that's what we want we want Scoops 16
boards last MAV game they had Joker 10
boards so
listen the thing about the Mavs that's
interesting is they are definitely a
feaster famine team they're going to
shoot a lot of Threes there could be a
lot of opportunities for boards so 10
rebounds feels like a very very solid
number for someone like Joker just to
get hey Ryan I know you were a wizard at
uh the you know controlling the FanDuel
page uh yes is there an option bro is
there an option for alternate rebounds
because somebody is in the comment
saying you can go to alternate rebounds
to get the nine is there an option for
that or no uh not to get the nine to get
the ten and that's what I plugged in
here so all right that's what we're at
right now and that's good
that looks good so we got what four legs
just to recap quickly we have Luca two
threes jokic 10 boards and then Ryan
what do we have for uh Cavs we have
LeBron over 26 and a half and Westbrook
over six and a half assists which we're
gonna have to Circle back on in a few
minutes here but yeah we're definitely
gonna start go back on the brown one uh
but I got Dominic schultzman he's saying
Jamal Murray points yeah
uh 19 and a half
just a little dub
I don't hate that
can we eat right Greg you're the numbers
guy can you pull up his stats recently
see how many times he's gone over 20.
my boy Jamal Murray let me let me look
him up let me see man uh while you do
that I'm in the chat and I'm saying
believe in the Reeves for rebounds we
did have Austin Reeves in a parlay
before and he definitely came through
for us so we can definitely go back yeah
uh relino best says A.D for one made
three I saw that I saw that the 80 May
uh for one may three uh to answer your
question bowling we got 18 points 20 26
31-21 in his last five
um
yeah I think this is going to be a track
meet I think that this is a game that's
going to be really high scoring I think
you know for for a lot of reasons 20
points doesn't seem like a lot I wonder
what the chat thinks Sylvester boy says
Murray good for a 20 piece nugget with a
check mark I love those vibes so might
be a leg here
might be a leg you're in rebounds Ryan I
think you're looking for three pointers
right
uh we're gonna talk about for a day yeah
no they don't have a free d up
unfortunately so I was looking at
rebounds because somebody said AR
uh oh AR-15 my bad brother my bad my bad
no no you're good but his line is two
and a half so that's gonna be uh as uh
Randy Jackson would say it's a no for me
dog
hey but I think me and bowling we might
got something here with Jamal Murray uh
just go to it Ryan just go to it why you
go to it the people are going to fill up
the comments and let us know if they
like the Jamal Murray to get a 20 piece
McNugget tonight against those uh Dallas
Mavericks who's gonna guard them
it's a good question
so that would probably fall on Tim
Hardaway Jr and Dory and Finney Smith
um who are good Defenders I mean like
those aren't bad Defenders I think Jamal
Murray's still probably getting his legs
back from his injury but you know the
numbers haven't lied he's had a bunch of
you know pretty he's been over four out
of the last five games and I expect a
lot of points in this game so could be a
good play whoa
that's what it would look like in the
parlay now I can't I can't see it
ten to one isn't that what you guys want
plus one thousand sorry uh
kinda
we're gonna get the money back y'all
wait no wait wait I'm so confused right
now
Ryan why are you hesitant bro usually
you want like 22 21-1 odds and this is
ten to one and you're being hesitant
what's we need a Vibe check what's going
on I just like I don't feel like we have
enough like safe in the bank legs I feel
like we have a lot of
right on the line
you know like we also have a lot of
overs too
okay I prefer to buy some stuff down I
also I would be one to suggest Cavs
money line
this is
well we're gonna have to unpack that in
a second but we do have we do have a lot
of good takes in the chat
Jaden Joyner says Westbrook six assists
Cavs gives up the mo the second most
assists to point guards Westbrook's line
is only at six we've been down this road
because we were going to do six but we
don't need to buy Six because we have a
hook on the original line Ryan's
argument is if we buy it down to six we
avoid a bad beat and we're already at a
ten to one parlay so I get where you're
coming from Ryan
if we want to kind of scale it back a
little bit I'm not against it
and we still got to talk about A.D
versus LeBron because a lot of people
are saying we need to swap out
LeBron and put in A.D
okay so that's what it does to the
parlay if we get six pluses this you've
just got the good news
this is an NBA show but yes uh no way
talk about the parlay
stop you're doing this you're you're a
you're a wizard Greg you got too much
going on all right so we moved it down
to six is that what we did right yes and
yes we're still at eight to one
yes
so I don't hate it hey hey I I also saw
another one um
what do we have now Ryan go over it
so we got Luca two plus threes jokic ten
plus rebounds Jamal Murray over 19 and a
half points LeBron over 26 and a half
points and Westbrook six plus assists
and what what's the odds
plus 801
. don't hate that how are you feeling
about it right what about the LeBron
James let's let's add the audience
all right here we go let's do Let's do
let's do this let's do this
I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go unpack something real quick
I'm gonna be right back okay but when I
go and practice because it we just got
breaking news we just got breaking news
I'm gonna go unpack this but when I come
back I want thumbs up thumbs up if you
guys want LeBron James to stay in the
parlay thumbs down
if you guys want to replace them with ad
thumbs up if you guys want LeBron James
thumbs down if you guys want to replace
them with ad let us know uh you guys
talk real quick I'm about to go unpack
this real quick because uh I just got
some breaking news
this is ridiculous I can't believe
what's happening right now but I respect
it I know exactly what he's going to do
but I have no idea what he's going to do
this guy's this got me looking at my
phone to see if like breaking news
happened here I have no idea what's
going on we'll figure it out let's let's
stay focused let's stay here we are
going to figure out whether or not we
need A.D or Lebron in this parlay people
are in the chat Darian my boy Darian
from the shy he's saying
LeBron 25 points I see a thumbs up from
bc21 I see a thumbs down from Red Mac I
see a thumbs up from secure2 and Wayne
60. lots of thumbs up I think everybody
loves LeBron tonight unfortunately Greg
unless you're on board so that was a
quick unpacking what do you think
uh so everybody's rocking with Brian it
looks like it
I like it I like it he's going back he's
going but what did the commenter say
earlier he said he's going back to play
his old team he's going back to
Cleveland back to his hometown he's
going to want to show up
he's going to want to show up I don't
hate it
so Ryan's argument is do we just tease
it down to 25 I'm just kidding I don't
want to open this can of worms
does the chat want to tease it down to
25. I wonder if the chat feels
differently than we did just 10 minutes
ago okay so definitely they don't
wartise saying LeBron always pops off in
Cleveland lots of thumbs up lots of
thumbs up so listen you guys are are
driving this parlay the the people are
speaking and the people the people look
like they want LeBron in there
yes uh
there's the chat is breaking news
in here is this is this real
it is is this real what you mean is it
real I just I just want to go and pack
for a reason it's real I just saw it
it's raining
you guys we are
no no this is an NBA show this is the
NBA show all right Ryan how are we on
Miss parlay what what are the odds I'm
sorry we gotta lock back in guys we we
have five picks we have five picks right
honestly in all honestly go look at 15
plus or like let's let's be real like
okay all right okay all right all right
actually like
and and that wasn't from me I'm sorry
guys that was from a commenter
they said Jamal Murray 15 plus uh 15
plus all right uh take it out let's go
to 15 plus
minus 400 at 520. I see if we're gonna
do five legs I think we need to sit at
at least 600.
20.
we have Luca two threes we have jokic 10
boards we have Murray 15 points you know
how we can get back to 600.
Russell Westbrook back to six and a half
and we're at six hundred we're like
above 600. that feels like a play
yeah all right I like that more yeah I
like that more Jamal Murray to get 15
rusts to go cook
all right well don't say Russ and cook
we know how that goes
since we're all over the place yeah uh
I like this what's that rhyme
that would be plus 681. now I want the
chats thoughts on this all right so now
we need to now we need to figure out if
they really like the full parlay so for
me the one thing that I'm hung up on is
LeBron would we feel safer with him two
plus threes
he does shoot a lot of them now I mean I
personally wouldn't mind that what's the
what's his number for threes what would
that do it it's at two and a half right
now
so then two plus would be minus 330 is
probably not going to do as well who's
that for who's that foreign
are we trying to take out his points and
put the threes in there yeah yeah do you
think
what do you think
oh the audience didn't I'm sorry no I
mean the audience is down honey like do
we want to do I mean Jared Allen's out
tonight
yeah that's a good Scoop that's a good
spot my my valuation on 80 though my
evaluation on ad is he plays better when
the competition is better
so ah good take
you know all right I have I have a
wrench to throw at you guys
go ahead Jay Hernandez Tim Hardaway Jr
been killing it on the threes clorash
Tim Hardaway over 3.5 made threes t
Williams says lock that
Chef Cape is saying why didn't you
mention the Hardaway threes Junior three
or Hardaway Junior three's play
people are speaking man I don't know if
we want to have four plays from that one
game but it sounds like I don't believe
that hey guys hear this one now Ryan you
might like this one res Mac 23 says
LeBron got the ankle injury as a Laker
fan Braun to cover is not going to be
easy A.D in all caps a d is going to
cover
and Wayne Wayne 60 is saying I like a d
tonight if Alan's not playing we did say
that so
call me crazy what if we took LeBron
under 26 and a half points
this is actually crazy because the
entire chat is saying over and then
we're gonna just flip no
can I ask the child no yeah yeah let's
thumbs up right thumbs down thumbs up or
thumbs down if you're all in on LeBron
uh under 26 and a half points we gotta
get a Vibe check Gotta Get A vibe let me
look up LeBron's numbers in recent in
recent games
with the the chat just mentioned that
he's he's had an ankle injury
I I have been told that it's confused
that my my gesture was confusing thumbs
up is you would like to take the under
thumbs down is shut up Ryan let Greg
talk
I'm not gonna lie hey somebody said
absolutely not hey I'm not gonna lie
Ryan that might be the worst take
of 2022 to be like LeBron
unless
five games or
yeah five games 29 28 31 39 and 21. okay
this is locky bro we have it rebound
this is it this is it yeah I'm not gonna
lie we might as well just rock
yeah this is it all right chat chat let
us know Brian get over the parlay this
is it tell us thumbs up if you like it
thumbs down if you don't
Luka doncic two plus threes uh jokic ten
plus rebounds Jamal Murray 15 plus
points LeBron over 26 and a half points
Russell Westbrook over six and a half
assists wait wait Ryan I'm so sorry what
did you tell the chat put thumbs down
for what because I see a lot of thumbs
down
uh they might be on the uh they might
still be telling me that uh my LeBron
take was trash
[Laughter]
Patrick Patrick BRAC said you are crazy
so I was yeah I asked for it to be fair
I did I did ask for that okay I'm sorry
Ryan I apologize and I know you repeated
the parlay like seven different times
but I think we I think we're feeling
good I think we're feeling good about
this parlay and we're gonna lock it in
can you repeat the parlay with the odds
for us one more time yeah sure real
quick uh AK-47 says Ryan needs some milk
I don't know
he needs some milk
I I don't know what that means I'm gonna
repeat this parlay one more time AK-47
please explain what that means uh Luka
doncic two plus made threes Nikolai
jokic ten plus rebounds Jamal Murray 15
plus points uh Lebron James over 26 and
a half points Russell Westbrook over six
and a half assists you add that all
together you get a five leg same game
parlay Plus on the NBA on TNT games that
adds up to Plus 681.
and remember if you bet you get your
money back if it doesn't hit so if you
don't sweat five dollars no sweat 25 to
win 170. no swings no sweat this no
sweat go get shot go chat
yeah we're locking this in we're not
going back I'm calling it putting my
foot down putting the stamp on it we are
locking this parlay in you guys can tell
with this arm FanDuel just like my man
Mike Bowman said
free it's like no you don't lose any
money if the BET loses it's free it's a
free Road no sweating you don't you
don't but remember Greg that if LeBron
scores 25 or 26 uh just remember to drop
droppy uh drop me your venmo so okay but
what if he does go over so do the do I
win
no no see you're you're in a lose-lose
situation because I will not give you
your credit if he goes over but I will
blame you if he doesn't got you got you
got you all right let's hop in this chat
let's talk let's see what the people are
talking about is there any bets to grade
are they giving us any other parlay legs
and we'll just grate them because we
already locked in our parlay we already
locked in our parlay but you guys
probably have other legs and we'll grade
you guys's legs and hey you guys could
probably go put those in the single beds
yes sir uh all right so we got uh Geo
pink saying Lonnie Walker over now let
me go check the points see what that is
uh 12 and a half over 12 and a half
points from geopink
I like that play
yeah we we had Lonnie Walker in our
first parlay that we made and he hit I'm
pretty certain so love those vibes shout
out to you 12 and a half points feels
like an easy one for him he does it all
I mean he's playing inside and outside
so definitely like that Play If I Had
degraded I'd give it a B plus
yeah I'll give it a solid B I like it I
like it in order for them to win Lonnie
has to score so uh
12 12 and a half hit a couple threes I
like it
shout out to m m hustle in the chat says
how do we get the no sweat money back
first thing you must be betting on
FanDuel second thing go up to the top
bar and click opt-in before you put the
parl in and don't add any legs from
games that are not on TNT so
Cavs versus Lakers Mavericks versus
Nuggets if you tail our parlay I think
you get your money back up to 25 dollars
and that's it that's the rules there it
is Ryan two more two more uh
commentaries that we're gonna get up out
of here you guys yeah a lot of money all
right real quick darian85 says someone
get Ryan some almond milk what does this
mean I got you
what does this mean
it's a very uh it's a this is what it
means
this is what it means this is what you
need Ryan you need to drink some of this
and get right I like how my man said
almond milk shout out to that guy he
drinks quality milk quality he knows I
can't do dairy he knows I can't do it uh
Robert pesantis says Ryan over three and
a half terrible takes before this ends
this is so good yeah this is the
funniest show because the the chat has
been like so connected to Ryan for like
a month and they finally are just
ripping him apart
I'm not afraid of you Chad I'll keep
reading I'll keep reading your comments
All Night Long uh Wayne 60 Max truce uh
over two and a half threes tonight
fun fact about Max struce he went we
went to the same exact College he went
to Lewis University shout out Lewis
University before he went to DePaul I'm
taking the over this is an A plus plus
take I love it hey I know you see the
chat Ryan I know you see all the
Laughing emojis They're laughing at the
almond milk
and Brad's saying I like skim milk what
is with the milk
you need to drink some that's what
they're telling you hey we're gonna get
on up out of here we're gonna get on up
out of here I'm going to send Ryan like
a couple batches of almond milk so you
can get right for the next show for next
Tuesday
um let's review the parlay one more time
Ryan I know I had you do like five
different times bread maybe seven but uh
the producer whispered in my ear and
told me to tell you to review the parlay
so go ahead give it to the people oh
look at this we got it built out on the
screen here uh Luka dances two plus
threes uh jokic 10 plus rebounds your
mom Murray 15 plus points LeBron over 26
and a half points Russell Westbrook over
six and a half assists and as you see
here when you add that all up in a five
leg parlay it comes out to Plus 681.
there it is there it is that is the part
that we are rocking with make sure you
guys tell us and ride with us on fan
duel my name is Greg the guy next to me
I call him MB but that stands for
Michael Bolin and next to him is the man
we like to call
producer Ryan
we out of here man I was gonna make a
milk joke Ryan but I'm like
okay
but this is this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna drink something peace guys
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]